AI
it's the reason you can watch this video
right now
no really
mu zero and AI program is helping this
video travel across the internet to you
but it didn't start out this way
it started with games
at Google deepmind we've always loved
games
goal chess even video games like Atari
playing any game well is about assessing
your environment planning your next move
and making good decisions
we wondered what if an AI program could
do all this with zero help from us no
game strategies not even the rules so we
built it
an AI program that taught itself how to
play games Win games and then how to do
it in the smartest way
that's what mu zero does it assesses
plans and then decides its best next
moves
and now it's making moves in the real
world too it's helping us with complex
tasks
compressing videos just like this one so
everyone can stream them smoothly using
less data and this is just a star AI
models like new zero are making software
work seamlessly
ensuring data centers are more energy
efficient
optimizing the Computing ecosystem that
powers our entire world of devices at
Google deepmind we've created AI
programs that are great at playing games
but what we're really doing is pushing
them to discover new skills so that the
AI we create is as useful and helpful as
we all need it to be